there's a story i haven't really covered
that much because
i i personally don't care about it but
at this point it is now
actually telling us something about the
culture the bachelor
you know the bachelor apparently there's
a host of the bachelor named chris
harrison hadn't heard of him until about
a week or two ago
he's not going to be returning to the
show he's been hosting this thing
forever apparently
and there's a controversy because chris
harrison made comments
a bachelor contestant who or
bachelorette or something i don't know
who had attended an antebellum south
party
years prior when she was in college here
was his
commentary on it what are your thoughts
about
rachel kirknell and the allegations
attached to her a couple of things first
and foremost i don't know
um i haven't talked to rachel about it
and and this is again
where we all need to have a little grace
a little understanding a little
compassion because i've seen some stuff
online
again this judge jury executioner thing
where people are just tearing this
girl's life apart and diving into like
her parents and her parents voting
record and what it's it's
unbelievably alarming to watch this
i haven't heard rachel speak on this yet
and until i actually hear this woman
have a chance to speak
who am i to say any of this um you know
i saw a picture of her at a sorority
party
five years ago and that's it like boom
like okay well this this girl
is in this book now and she's now in
this group and i'm like
really oh chris oh
poor sweet chris you
you do not know what kind of a situation
you are in politically right now and
unfortunately
he made in not only did he make the
wrong
choice there if he wanted to keep this
mainstream gig to
contradict the pc police but he has
subsequently made
every other wrong decision
very important to note what he actually
did because people are saying it was he
made a racial comment and this and that
a girl who was on the show attended a
party in college
that was about the south the antebellum
south
and so they dressed up like the
antebellum south
so you have to believe that that was
vicious and vile and racist okay people
are debating that
you have to believe then that it matters
that she went to this party years ago
and you have to believe that it is it is
a political crime
for this guy to defend this girl
from having her life destroyed for
something she did years ago by just
showing up to a party
but chris didn't realize that and chris
fell into a huge
pc trap chris harrison of bachelor fame
defends the contestant for attending a
party that was politically incorrect
years prior fine i actually sort of give
him credit for saying we need a culture
of grace we don't
we shouldn't just be jumping on top of
one another and trying to destroy each
other's livelihoods all the time in bad
faith
but then he made a fatal error and i
don't think anybody's going to be
defending him anymore
he apologized for
encouraging grace and for defending the
girl
why would you defend rachel kirknell i
am an imperfect man
i made a mistake and i own that
i believe that mistake doesn't reflect
who i
am or what i stand for
i am committed to the progress not just
for myself
also for the franchise so this is
pitiful to watch a grown man do this but
it's it's also
despicable because he was making a
principled stand to say no i'm going to
defend this
girl who was a contestant against the
mob for doing something that should not
cause her to have her life ruined that
was a principled stand now she's ju
and now he's throwing that all under the
bus right he's throwing the girl under
the bus and he's also saying i i'm
throwing my past
self under the bus for even considering
defending her he's totally undermining
the principle to me i see no reason
to defend this guy anymore i'm sure the
reason he did it is because he's weak
and that's very sad
but what can you do i was debating this
issue with megyn kelly last week i was
on megan kelly's podcast
which you can download it's out now and
we were debating this apology
she was the one who called this guy to
my attention because i never
couldn't have picked him out of a lineup
i hadn't you know you'd be shocked to
hear i don't i don't watch the bachelor
all the time
and negan said look i get it he's got a
good gig
all these guys were talking about the
mumford and sons musician
uh now his name escapes me too uh
all these people who were constantly
being canceled and then they cave to the
woke mob
and and megan said look it's a good gig
and so
i get it this is what traditionally is
what people do and
i pointed out to her i said yes in the
past
even if you think it's kind of silly you
contravene whatever the fashionable
political
ideas are of the day you apologize
especially if you do something actually
wrong you apologize and then people
forgive you and that's that
but that's not what's happening right
now the choice is not between
speak out against the mob stand up for
grace stand up for the girl
and lose your job and
don't cave to the mob but keep your job
that's not the choice
you've already lost your job the only
question is are you going to degrade
yourself further
it reminds me of one of the last scenes
of breaking bad
way toward the end of the series spoiler
alert if you haven't seen it but it was
on what like 10 years ago so you know
you missed your window for for spoilers
the brother-in-law the cop
brother-in-law hank is lying there on
the ground
walter the the drug runner is
there he said he's pleading with hank he
says hank please
just tell this cartel kingpin type guy
just tell him you you'll protect him you
won't
turn him in you won't go after him just
please just beg for your life
and then he'll let you live and the cop
hank has one of the most memorable lines
in tv
hank sent to me
you gotta tell me you gotta tell him now
that we can work this out
please please
what he want me to beg
you're the smartest guy i ever met
and you're too stupid to see
he made up his mind 10 minutes ago
do what you're gonna do
you're the smartest guy i ever met
you're too stupid to see he made up his
mind 10 minutes ago
do what you're going to do the mob made
up their mind
for all these people like chris harrison
the mumford and sons musician
the mob already made up its mind the the
end more to it the people who have
crafted political correctness already
made up their mind
the only question is are you going to
degrade
yourself if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content out there
you